[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello
happy Friday me and Rob are back cuz we
never leave you guys I guess we're doing
the same thing except sort of different
in the sense that Star Wars Battlefront
2 has gone into open beta that was like
a 1:00 a.m. Pacific Standard Time which
was like 10 hours ago
but now if you wanted to play the game
now's your chance
it's until the end of the weekend yeah
so so here we go Boba Fett Bubba Fett
both it Boba Fett alright yeah that's
him
you got any emotes no no victory poses
I'm offline you're offline what do you
mean you're offline uh-oh you know we
should do I'm plug the the other not
you're the other guy the the blue line
one because we we're trying to do this
thing where we were downloading in
parallel to Rob's machine because we're
having that problem again but then we
found another workaround the problem
where the HDMI was not being read yeah
but I hope this is so awkward come on
stay on target come on there we go oh
nothing happened we're good nothing
happened and guess what oh my god area I
got a crate
I got a crate dude oh I love crates
silently clearly sound like ether I feel
like we should make a video of all the
crate games in 2017 it would be a witch
crate is the best which is your best
loot crate opening experience right it'd
be a long oh look at this oh hey
crafting parts I from what I've heard
from you is that it's it comes at a
premium so yeah you want those Oh Boba
Fett fuel efficiency don't want that
common
I don't want hey you don't want that
alright let's get into a game Rob damn
right what do you want to play first
start off with the you should use a
galactic assault mm-hmm
right has anything really changed for
you since yesterday no not quite
so special listing it I was Han Solo got
killed by Darth Maul just like in the
movies
that's what happened yesterday that's
canon someone was asking how is darth
maul fighting Yoda yeah so you know they
kind of get away with it though right
with the like whole how they're doing it
with the timeline stuff that's kind of I
mean but no but then again no cuz Han
Solo and Darth Maul were versus each
other ever at any point ever time travel
or rey rey for that matter it's even
more of a stretch I don't know I I we
were talking the other day I was I'm I'm
hoping for a mode that is like just
infantry and just you know no heroes or
villains whatever they're that cool also
just so you guys know I will be in
YouTube twitch chat cancer chat so if
you guys have questions or opinions I
will share those with Rob and as Rob
tries to kick some clone or you on the
droid side here and they say clone but
we will do our best
oh oh they are already firing dude are
you sure your civilians what animals
well yeah we hate civilians this is no
Russia oh [ __ ] a chap no no I can't do
it here okay no I have so I got an
attachment for this weapon that is an
ion barrel so it's it does more damage
to vehicles and turrets and machines but
less damage to infantry I don't know if
I want that right now see it's blue okay
I do website a two time scope on it look
at that nice what's up Jacob
the Homer Homer are you doing how's
everyone doing today it is free mr.
shotguns go open beta is available for
everyone today I think there's one
behind you a heavy great that's fine I
can you know Wow
it's all the shield barely Jack a asking
what is the best class to use rob um
I've been hearing good things about
specialists and heavy rifle especially
heavy is like what I just got killed by
you know you're you're kind of like
support ish tank with just like a nice
minigun I still think that it's
important for teams you have officers
but obviously might be a little bit
tougher for people to get into that
right away yeah like you talked about it
again like yesterday but like you know I
the game tells you the beginning on this
during the spawn like hey if you stick
near your you know these three other
guys you're gonna get more experience do
we determine that though as a fact and
now that just drew just like with your
actual team oh oh these guys are crazy
which is Koch trying to come in
willy-nilly the clone brothers that
they're crazy oh yeah what is that oh
this pulse rifle type oh why am I stuck
I got stuck in his body gun you're using
that sounds different than yesterday no
so that is um it's one of my abilities
like like I think oh dude this thing I
was using this thing yesterday oh I
can't use it I know I know but like if
you speed up you get the points and then
you can use it really
oh this it's just an ability to like I
think it like disrupts enemy like
scanning but also has like that yeah
that like auto like hipfire I had a nice
little burst yeah kind of like it was
burst firing like a pulse rifle is their
best automatic weapon JJ is asking I've
been using a lot of the specialist I
mean I think the assault hasn't good
stuff with this guy except they're not
there's I don't you know I can't really
say I mean like thing is is that you
know you have in the in debater there
are two weapons the second one you can
unlock the second one you can unlock has
mod attachments scope on and like good
eye on extension or there's another one
I got hip fire thing I don't know but I
would say I'd say you would want to like
get that weapon and mess around with it
but think it just takes so damn long to
like get these attachments on so it's
like I just don't know enough about all
the way there yet
yeah they they - I guess thanks Jay Voss
Alonso for the sub yeah if you guys
haven't already subbed obviously we'd
appreciate it if you did because it'll
help notify you guys when we go live
also when we make cool features we go
live every day at 11 a.m.
squicky TV it's not on Steam it's on
origin for PC we are currently playing
on PC but it should also be out on the
consoles as well right Rob yeah so open
beta already beta open beta the O for
this guy if you don't know what's going
on here the clones are trying to use
it's like a destructor cannon that are
like at certain points and they want to
fire it on an empty T here to disable
shield so they then they can attack and
destroy it before we storm their Palace
vivec asking are there any grenades for
this class oh yeah they are can you show
them sure I can aid those and those you
can change like an ion grenade again
that will disable shields and do more
vehicle damage I think I have that
apparently a hilarious glitch but I
can't talk about always time I'm gonna
I'm just gonna go with the maybe we'll
try it later right now we're trying to
get that hot ship action I do like the
flying a lot yeah that's what they
wanted the biggest things for you other
than just the spectacle and how
beautiful it looks
yeah it does look good this guy he
thinks you got just a minigun he's way
out of here and no see the good news is
Rob there's a lot of day 1 babies today
although it's time to take advantage of
the day ones cuz they don't know what's
up YouTube Empire how are you doing
today thanks for tuning oh that actually
hurt you fine alright
officers can put down those turrets if
you saw that turret that's what a
officer that's one of those abilities
you can see look at this guy under here
he's chillin man he's protecting it it's
like a sauna that feels good on his
robot body putting up his pores yeah we
can show off some first-person and how
people always want to see that Oh
Mohammed Amin a Ben Sultana it is out
for TCE on the origins so go to origin
download that oh yeah the droids classic
Bhama I I was doing some some work with
one of these the other day yeah these
look so cool I don't I don't remember
these ones have been the the TV show
Clone Wars I've never seen these I just
really hoped you can last long enough
here before you get to the next phase
because once you get past phase one you
will no longer be able to fly this I
believe right that's what happened
yeah so let's do some work with the
bomber here know what's going on
uh-oh that was a little close dude yeah
it was Oh too close for comfort combat
time this this well this ship though I
will say like it's interesting because
it it sounds not like this Rob okay it
sounds really quiet
why else like is a Honda Odyssey of Star
Wars it's not the original trilogy you
know it's it yeah not result philippi it
is what it is a y-wing though republic
while yeah can all those asking on
Origin open beta also haven't controls
so Dan this guy's got the Jukes with
this badass ship like this guy he's got
terrible aim and by this guy I mean Rob
how dare you come here
the ticking tick 73 is like please leave
me alone
alright God I'm Rob good job do you have
any add-ons for this this ship or does
it affect yeah I don't remember what
though the Interceptor Starfire class I
hope you will my grad countermeasures
fast ends Malone we're playing galactic
assault that is the game type we're
trying to storm that Palace right I
think
yeah well the clones try to hold on for
dear life guy is quick this guy's got
the moves he's got the shakes
they interceptor I'm just gonna slow ass
bomber so if you don't go after the
aerial guys can you go after the the
ground units yeah but it's just not
worth it well I don't want to get rekt
to some like making a strafing it's fine
no we good we good you play the way you
want to I don't want a backseat Drive
how big is the arena if you're flying it
seems decently sized it'll tell you
obviously when you're out of the out of
zone oh is anyone down there
Oh looks like you're about to take over
or get into the face
- are you bringing it yeah right
I tried it when I planted III I tried
doing that with them to boost our
fighters didn't go well oh I think it
was bigger than 16 gigs um crazy 99s why
is he asking you remember how big the
file size was but that was like 22 on PC
but we'll see remember get your faces
off the screen don't want to see that
you're the only one that's so my car
come on like a like oh alright I'll
indulge Jim for a second yeah I don't
care let the game but there's nothing in
the top left anyways yeah
we're still gonna talk over Michael yeah
we're still gonna do that that's for
sure whoa look at that
wild poby oh that was a guy those duking
you in there oh yeah okay so currently
he's playing heavy if you guys didn't
even switch to the heavy class the heavy
class has the mini minigun as an ability
so this is a new start card I put on man
a launcher sick try it out give them the
business Oh does that go through the
shield good enemy sentry gun be careful
okay they know you're there Oh - OH -
tango why am i moving oh he threw an
electric or an ion grenade wow they're
all derecho me you here we go
BT RP rocket droid ps4 16px thanks Jamie
Robert for that information beta is free
for all is a day until the end of the
weekend so enjoy that if you want to
play it
hit that asking what's your favourite
hero or the beta I haven't really played
a lot of Heroes yeah so there's only two
per team and you have to be doing pretty
well to use them right like how many
points is it for a hero like 5000 yeah
okay so we just spent 2,000 this guy so
if you like double this guy
oh I almost had that guy my way dude I
do like the oh yeah
I do like the hero chips like slave
wanna slave one yeah your we can do some
Starfighter stuff in a little bit so you
guys can check that out is gonna go but
I actually like the boots on the ground
experience Oh mall get them all and I'm
dude that's no so low I totally killed
myself I'm solo dolo is out Jar Jar is
the best hero dude that evil Jar Jar
thing was true and he's like a Sith Lord
and then he's that unlockable if he do
with some certain code that we think I
think that that jar jar's if theory
theory is I think it actually may have
been true at one point and then Lucas
abandoned it after everyone initially
thought dr. with the worst thing ever
created but what if he's just acting
that dude that'd be the greatest thing
of all time I know if he just like one
from me just like oh yeah the change
this boy is that he was playing everyone
the whole time totally yeah oh yeah
hi guys yeah is this the like main
throne room here SIF hearts Shekar
assume I said his name right does it
feel like a battlefield the one in
reskin no no God
fainting I wish it was more like
battlefield one like namely like just
the structure of like squads like not
these random squads we're like I'm gonna
lose my guys in one second like I want
to I want to see my squad consistently
in be and so is that Ray I saw a blue
Sabre man yeah yeah give her the
business
I still hear it and it terrifies me that
was a droid I'd be terrified of hearing
[Music]
oh yeah oh no it seemed like it was
gonna be good luck I had a lot of star
cards yeah I saw three so I'm saying
dude star cards they were all like like
fairly like high level to hilarious this
is totally fake but gives that's like
it's true bro if you get a hundred
player killer streak with all heroes you
unlock charts are you guys all on that
one
you know do this go I'll get them all
just hosing them down hard it was a
firefight we'll play as all the wings at
some point as many as the game offers
yeah doesn't have the B wing no B wing
yeah and it switches sides right to be
fair here yeah well we'll be cloned now
which is cool I do like the new boost
off I did
Donovan's token er yes you could
technically have a set squad if you join
together before you search for a match
but what Rob's talking about is more
like specifically like squads my base
stuff in the game yeah Thank You
Jonathan I know I swear I liked how I
thought I knew what you were talking
about right the idea the idea that I
have a squad but the same squad
throughout the match so I can basically
look at my squad and think okay you know
what we don't need everyone to be an
officer I'll be something different yeah
because then you can tell on your squad
like okay that guy's playing right
officer right I should yeah and even
like a squad leader could be helpful
because when everyone spawns everyone's
like where do we go no one's thinking
the same necessarily there's there are
different objectives so like they're
just times were just like you everyone
immediately separates and it's tough to
like I think stick around with those
guys but if you had even like the
ability to see differentiate your team
from your squad mates like green and
blue like alpha one that'd be killer to
have you played on console yet at all no
no we have not I'm just curious like
Jaime Robert asks just how they stack up
against each other yeah Vitara asking
does this feel more like the old-school
battlefront
I know differ it feels very similar to
last game that's all say I mean but you
said for the better though right yeah
definitely
it's pretty hard to compare like the
last games today I feel like the
previous oh oh you're not already oh
[ __ ] you're right that's weird
swish good job Joe you got my name right
all right
most of the time I butcher names
sometimes we get it wrong just feels
good we get it right
no this officer has like a burst fire
nice very nice well I think this is my
teammate so as the officer that's what
he's playing he can buff his teammates
also drop a turret as I had mentioned
earlier Oh walk out yeah sometimes he
sends his teammates out into the fray oh
no real life yes you are
oh that's the flashbang that uh that I
officer has as well that Aaron was
talking about that disorient on team
Aaron was saying this is really good for
like some of those rooms you have to
capture because you throw that in and
then you buff your squad and then you
guys all roll in together while they're
blind and smoke them or ideal situation
obviously so what is that buff do um
another officer oh god no I'm not gonna
do that
damnit no come on
okay anyways it I believe it's a damage
boost as well as like increases the
damage you can take big dumb dodo yeah
oh my god have a turd on their ass no I
didn't work out Center oh this guy so I
hope that's fine this is good
I'm really like day one guys that was
such a dark laughs you will die alright
these guys yeah this is what was
happening to us yesterday like people
don't know the map yet clearly again
again their butts blanks left them right
up now you're gonna bow bow Fetty WAP
that was a decent streak I would say oh
yeah baby
Oh sick okay uh can you 80s wall in
third person yes right oh you know what
what let's show this sure the tribal
fighter sounds so sick dude
so sick oh sorry did you hear my
question thought turns up no what was it
can you 80s in third person
the 80s yes oh no no only certain weapon
no I said the sniper rifle doesn't so
fast and it sounds so awesome he's got
something similar I feel like yeah he
does oh it sounds so great
getting a little sick watching yeah it's
all good though no that's right I don't
know Oh God
come here
oh he knows
it's money chasing a guy while you're
chasing him yep he needs that my Jew
Deniz just chill out and then this guy
will stay straight yeah that was great
leading the shots to so cool he's right
ah you know what
Oh paintin runyan asking hey you pick if
you're a clone trooper or a droid I
think so yeah at least not right now not
in beta when he matched me ricocheted
but for the most part you you go back
and forth that 3ch mad mop them up
little strafing run that guy totally
crashed yeah but you didn't oh I see guy
oh damn they don't highlight them at all
for me you know it's tough it's tough
that's kind of cool though so it's not
too overpowered no but again the one I
was in before the bomber I can just like
free fire missiles in an area all right
yep sure what's your favorite ship to
use as a goob the Naboo Starfighter in
this map is pretty good the a wing the
alien Starfighter Saltz is pretty great
I'll revenge let's try this guy we
should get that at some point dude yeah
well I feel like you're gonna probably
push the point before that happens
you're the real president Trump I highly
doubt it
I'm what was that what there's a Donald
Trump in that chat oh there's no way
even if you were the real Donald Trump
actually you know what
I wouldn't put it past him to be
watching an YouTube family
you know it's kind of weird not the MTT
so what is that ship do for the other
there's this if it's just on Rails it's
like the ac-130 in battle yeah that'll
feel then you aim down with like a
turret he's just got the green turret
and then a day disappear serious yeah
oh shoot I don't know but it's not
looking good Rob b-wing it's fine
V is for victory try try one more you do
what you want to do alright I want to
see if I can get some good spawn kills
you would spawn kill a man it's tactic
no I know it's a it's been a viable
tactic in multiplayer shooters for a
long time
he's not the spawn killing I came to see
ya
I knew that was gonna happen oh he's got
the speed to take you down show him
you're a real pilot
[Music]
at least take some guys with you oh that
was close daddy he would crash yeah damn
that would have been nice I thought I
already if you could have like that like
when you pand your camera he just blows
up you got him here I'll be the MTT
turret she interests oh you can sit in
the turret yeah these things are pretty
overpowered I think not overpower but
they can they can get some kills
yeah Donovan that's a good point it
would be great
squad work if the specialist class could
highlight enemy soldiers for you on the
ground you can okay with the binoculars
come on really
oh I see you stinking loud no it's great
I love it
see you see your sniper scope
I don't think you wanted oh this guy is
courageous like this was a bad idea
how is he still alive oh you coming oh
you can't turn it that much at my range
look at this guy come on
oh I've what I have here no idea what to
see - oh your pleasure double your beams
I have no idea what the other two did
yeah that's the problem with those icons
I like don't know shift checked
Oh oh that's uh so that one is a Yantra
structure yeah you got your Q which is
that double fire oh they're right there
he's a health boost oh oh oh no what oh
maybe it was time I ran out just like
the the Walker from the last game oh you
know there on that that that building
over there yeah
nice oh [ __ ] he doing I was just looking
great those are luke rates he totally
got me all right see if I can save for
that oh I'm super close but I won't be
able to use it not phases over save it
for Boba Fett speed officer wall dude
your fifty hundred points away from wall
okay I think I went I think it would be
Bubba Fett above all what you think well
your Boba Fett's got better star cards
if that's oh no ray get out of here you
ray you're out of line overpowered Jedi
and and you're also out of the timeline
Knox King good luck with the nightfall
and se2 just find the anomalies or find
the cheese visit cheese i can't refute
his hot dog sick sick
well they fix battle time or will it
just be five to six minutes don't know
we'll see all right here we go what
looks like a Guardian tank from Broyhill
world was that bad you did oh it's just
like The Guardian rep in a while maybe
he's talking about your April oh hey ray
Oh wha Oh see this action come on go
fighter what are you doing are you
looking at your abilities oh yeah yeah
you got it you gotta take her down wall
this is a fight nope I want to use like
hope to many people nice good buff there
I like that was smart play there whoa
that was a tactical play Wow you shot
that guy in the head and this guy
oh no rays in there for sure
we're small what is mall doing oh you
just killed two people there or Keolis I
think you got this G G is for overriding
I guess oh yes what just disappeared
or did you never put it down oh I have
to fold this this is so slow amen you're
doing you're doing a team objective
you'll get a lot of points for your
cowboy know if that's true or not
what will dark be available I'm not sure
nuts game Luis Torres wants to know what
your feelings are about the arrow
crossover I don't I don't I don't like
at all and I just take out the the
heroes take all the heroes that's it I
hope I hope there's a a great job that's
you got a thousand for playing the
objective there feel like you're gonna
get that hot Bubba Fett action here in a
second well I had a glitch where I was
oh where I was the clone so in the last
phase the door slams shut and you can't
get through no this is they already news
I don't know it's crossed off so it
means there must be news wait yeah Boba
Fett our dress ball I don't know
whichever one comes up yeah I think
they're gonna dine you trying to say
that Darth Maul is playing like a real
real real slow
what's up McElroy I mean we should wait
yeah you think so yeah okay someone said
mall III think it's whoever he gets to
click on but here's the predicament it's
like you can save your points and never
get to play hero oh yeah
how come all says Maksimir and play but
you only have one here yes it does
I know but like so so you can't have you
can't have two no you can there are
currently there are Maul and Bubba that
you just can't have two a bunch of
duplicates I haven't died other walls or
effects come on no they're capturing the
primary objective Rob should I get in
there I don't know I just wanted a hero
me too
this is like this is the most points
you've ever had since yesterday you know
well man I'm gonna click this is it yes
yes can someone does it play the music
when he comes out when you come out I
doubt it Oh what if it did like that
Arcade Mode
[Music]
sorry what I had oh yes
who's next number is at the throw one oh
my god yes so much life mall has so much
life oh where is everyone
no no just getting rekt at this point oh
we don't care about mission areas Darth
Maul doesn't care about mission areas
find them Rob where you do not care
about spawn areas or do the doors not
open unless they open them know is this
Canon that was oh man that was canon me
actually this attack I think is is canon
apparently the the droids went back to
Naboo to attack yeah
Oh hub cat and if we just had like a
little bit more time it's still
frustrating though right like if I
really wanted to be a hero
it's so not guaranteed but dude and
twice I've seen haand and then the match
is over huh you see how him you got to
go imagine if you had three of em eh
he's just like hah yeah that's the best
line from Knox mall is a [ __ ] great
play the music - yeah I had that feeling
like alright I bet they're gonna give
you a little taste they know what's up
oh man that's great I hope we get to do
that again let's play one more just
because I feel like you might be able to
get another one okay hopefully maybe
both because I have yet I was really
dark are ya later Sam bro then we'll do
some Starfighter assault I know you
might want to see that but that was too
hot hot hot imagine if you just never
left the respawn or you just like I
don't care ten seconds to mop up you
can't pull me back think I genuinely
went in there and killed like 500 the
doors open I'll just see myself out now
okay yeah okay out of bounds sure I love
it oh cool I got another card slot card
slot another card slider let's see here
all your bilities recharge faster that
sounds pretty good my physician is just
Christopher Stein are there get overeats
in weapons let's try this out is that
like a brass knuckle yeah that's what I
thought overheats weapon diffuses
explosions what is it Abel's turrets
removes my turret that's fine I don't
really like that turret anyway no
disables turrets right I'm guessing it
to Scylla
oh I'm no I think it does I'm what I'm
saying is I didn't like my turret that I
had but dude that's like a what's a 1:1
box card stand for like a rare yeah this
is oh wait oh this is no this would be
so I think I figured out I think this is
for so this is this is uncommon common
oh sorry hold on right no no we got to
get rid of ours for you to show that do
that oh sorry I think it's not Daniel
there are four kind of tags on each card
right I think it's uncommon common rare
epic and then legendary cards look
completely different
I don't think we've gone a legendary
card yet Malik P uh asking brah is this
game more fluid than Battlefront one
mm-hmm more fluid I think this is this
is I think ultimately a better game than
your last suite sure okay I do think
that okay how come you only have a
pistol as this guy but your other guy
had like a pulse rifle type thing like
those rifle I may have switched weapons
that's fine
I like this it's like goldeneye show me
you can do work this is all I need you
know yeah the man with the Golden Gun
yeah
that's silver right you're good where's
your where your I don't know I lost my
already alright oh hi oh that's an
officer you think he's alone
oh that was a vanguard icon sounded
interesting so yeah it's there these are
completely different guns from the
officer on the droid army a tourism
that's interesting uh kids at saying I
hope Grievous becomes a hero bill and be
in the DLC very interesting for
lightsabers that'd be cool you know that
being ability star card ability or he
does that one move really like just like
yeah yes more of them they're all just
kidding right
that'd be pretty neat what if it was a
star card though I'm just kidding I
really didn't like that no it couldn't
happen guess what it's all I could yeah
stark Carter down some people Johnson oh
nine six four feels that battlefield
battlefield Battlefront to from oh five
OH six these years ahead of this the fun
fact is they they brought it back right
it's like back the servers were brought
back a little bit but it was still kind
of buggy the other day oh right yeah
they tried to bring them you know I got
any servers we the issue is like
whatever was called DirectX I thinking
of you like isn't compatible with like
Windows 10 or something like that like
so like it like it's it's super hard to
like get that thing running unlike
modern operating systems okay that was
kind of awkward and I know where he was
going
don't these guys don't droids remind you
dance a little bit let's try this thing
out if I throw it nope it looks kind of
like the slave one thing we just like a
impede their you okay I'm just kind of
farted right like you kind of like
always if you had like a seaport trigger
thing nice guy here behind you dude
they're chasing you for sure what I can
tell in the mini-map I saw a guy run
through
well the thing is we need to get this
someone get it you can squad up Tyler is
what people said but someone else also
mentioned that there might have been
some issues with friends joining in one
up oh damn let's try assault all right
let's try salt get me out of here
Anakin not a hero not that we know Darth
Vader Beta Beta
lose the pistol I'm driving eleven like
a champ
that was from fender freak t15 what's
the EE 11 of my question is that the
other weapon must be the other weapon
for us for officer cv8 answer wolfy says
i can't download the beta not sure why
you can't it should be open pcs on
Origin and I'm assuming on console you
if I just got search for it it's got to
be there you can also try it like those
things aren't working for you restarting
your select device it feels a little
quiet yeah and I'm an almost lost I
could turn it up no not not even use
acquired from like the opposite like the
yeah like the enemies aren't where are
people well when you hit tab was there
like a bunch of people yeah
do as much damage as that other game the
Gangstar behind me love you love you
alright and what kylo ren's says Payton
Runyan I wouldn't be shocked oh y-wing
action honda odyssey to kondeh ha to see
you of Star Wars
yeah I'm not 100% sure Tyler but I think
someone had mentioned you could squad up
so hopefully that works out for you
sorry if it doesn't but yeah
hello Marcus at fries Allison welcome to
the chat i bothering think that you've
got maneuverability that's not a bomber
what is it or not hi bomber which is
that the bomber that you play it's just
a droid one fighter I don't know no they
look they look extremely similar
interest got something fast on your six
doing the old Odyssey shaking bakes are
you good now pull like that up now
you're just a big boat that everyone
wants to r2 or some form of in our tunes
it's another Astro droid where
Oh a very different knox-keene I would
have compared to you J Garcia which
games are y'all excited for in the
coming weeks
well come on so like in 21 days there's
gonna be the the big triple which is
Mario Assassin's Creed and Wolfenstein
people within comes out before those
games obviously and so does the ward or
ward or without next week our reviews up
for Ward or actually Justin hey while
you do that seven out of ten oh that
looks kind of good I thought you were
good there it looks like you let's try
this out should've made it oh is this a
c-130 or yeah was it a c-130 yeah mainly
for the ground yeah there's a guy on the
ground - that's hilarious or was that
the ship and when I'm in the ship
great
I should have just objected yeah should
have knocking hi pretty well within
could be good we'll see I don't know if
all the way that it's too scary and I'm
huge on the horror stuff myself
oh nice
double yeah to time as we creep up up
there's a lot of action really close to
what Kyle said I'm all right no I think
you just got a you just gotta find your
way we are currently playing on PC Eric
go lay or gallop do they definitely not
Goulet it's either gallon or Calais go
gallop though
what's up super rubs gaming
oh yeah yeah this is good this is what
you want them to do wine oh yeah he's
lucky reload
oh he was born you got out of there good
have you guys tried Cohoes chi yeah
cuphead yes I love it oh yeah I just
started playing yesterday I got past the
first world enjoying it so far I heard
it ramps up quite a bit so looking
forward to that when I get to it but
yeah we're loving it Joey's loving it at
Joey's put out a bunch of stuff on our
YouTube channel he is really good at the
game you should check it out he has like
an expert expert mode no damage gameplay
compilation couple couple bosses it's
pretty impressive I have to say even
though he's my coworker yeah he's he's
pretty freakin good that game yeah we
can't play campaign because no single
player yet it is a beta sorry I think
Joey said that he is pretty close to
getting all s ranked and what a boss
unfortunately there's nothing you get
for your like they should be fun yeah
exactly
control a hot refund okay I just bought
this ship yeah right you've lied to me
what do you mean you can fly for five
minutes not even actually not even
all right here we go we're gonna hold
down the porch Oh butts all right oh you
got him anyways Gandalf the Grey oh is
that the ability one is that white
seeing that oh I was like this is gonna
be good
you do not have to pre-order the game
right now Rodimus Prime 29 great name
you got the touch you got the power it
is open beta today PC do it on origins
xbox one ps4 I'm guessing just search
for it in the store should be able to
get your hands on this yep it's a hot
statue this game really does look
oh-oh-oh they killed him I think was
their hero I heard some saber action all
right it hurts even I'm wearing a suit
oh oh yeah oh look at this movement Oh
Ray's going ham now go get him go get
him oh yeah oh yeah as the meat shield
yeah they're all focusing on her yep all
right I should go back yep yep you know
she do step a little bit of a mine here
I like it
it's devious it is available on PC it
kimochi sign on origin you have to
download origin first and probably
making the county go happen obviously
you got 2,100 now what's that
the Chuba I mean I might as well write
all right fine so do it
got no star parts that man oh well
actually these are locked oh there they
don't let you put star cards in New
Zealand why is that
I don't know yeah look at that jet pack
they let your boba fett oh you have a
rocket launcher - eww oh come on come on
all right
Starfire mode have you guys played the
strike yet on taco Donna yes yesterday
we haven't today
let's see Starfighter is taco down oh
just like you luck of the draw Oh
getting that or was there a specific
mode that would get you that no it's
it's we can play that if you okay yeah
let's do talk it on on yeah I haven't
had too much clamoring in the chat for
space stuff yet that's fine and actually
I'd rather play talk about dream so good
need popcorn
all right thanks Peyton appreciate that
taco Donna oh Donna we'll just call it
Moses Palace right yeah oh that's not it
all right we're doing the strike sixteen
players called pure infantry combat
which is feels like this
Lucas cake Rosenberg Philly Billy 18 how
long is the open beta for all weekend
yes should be till the end of the
weekend I will double-check the actual
end time but I believe it's still Sunday
open beta yeah
look GameSpot article no look we're live
on site yeah we are of course I should
change this video out ah let's see open
beta runs from now until October 9th at
9:00 a.m. Pacific 12:00 p.m. Eastern
which means you have till Monday morning
actually I lied I'm a bad person so yeah
you guys if you guys get in now you guys
have all weekend into Monday
and yes once you've done with the open
beta you can hang tight later that day
is the last Jedi trailer let's get muddy
it's weird that only your boots get
money though no your back should be
money right now right well okay so it
does happen I think it's like it just
happens later sorry okay okay a little
bit of frames there guys that was my bad
I was watching a stream of something
what's your favorite class asks what nub
gaming I've been playing specialists
this is the one I got going on right
here got like a nice sniper rifle and
this cool like this guys break free whoa
do you see your head helmet come on yeah
I know right it's not weird I know it
seems like cartoonish that was really
weird
yes I like specials though Erik gelett
Galit org la wants to show off some
character customization off and yeah we
can check that out and all this guessing
he means like the star cards and the
weapons and stuff like that got him you
gotta watch out for those guys up top
they sneaky sneaky
oops one grab the artifact of a reaction
in front of you here right like this
ruffling nice and [ __ ] Oh touch my rat
everywhere
touch with his name touch my rat like
that weird kid from school
why does my rat Oh God
the old jump away tactic
damn you guys so sorry guys alright
that's it
Oh specialist time yeah there's your mud
sick but that came off an explosion in
there but I like it
so nice touch yeah I'm so low bra Oh
what an idiot yeah we just like here let
me stop and uh let you shoot me in the
face
all right here we go here we go
little two streak right now we're gonna
get like a tense treatment don't fail me
Rob you're the elite Rob
nice that same guy he doesn't learn Rob
got a farm um no when you pick this up
you just keep slaying I think they're
flankin you nice no I called for a ten
streak leave him alone
oh he's probably a good spot
yeah that's pretty good run though just
needed the specialist your go-to
oh yeah
oh yeah give me the triple they're not
ready for you Rob you just needed some
music oh oh hey playing the objective
baby did you I was so close
no you didn't get that no so close it
was there's a meter man it was like good
play man he was like 80 I liked it that
role threw him off and yeah dude the
role
oh yeah do that
whatever power up this is really good oh
you got guys everywhere you're like damn
damn kinda like matrix some guys flank
him ooh ooh ooh I don't even know why
what do you got rocket trooper you look
a real clean though I like it
ah what I pushed the artifact back let's
just kick their ass I like it
oh there's there's a rocket trooper guy
Oh touching my rat no longer oh that was
those excellent hey someone clipped that
you see the big plays he made oh that's
dope oh he's going to hand now the
rocket launcher there that was that
ready I know I don't think was I'm just
saying you needed it there that would
have been clutch where's your favorite
NBA team warriors hands-down Golden
State
not a bandwagon er Ben fan since the
Latrell Tim Hardaway Chris Mullin way
back in the day
yikes touch my rats in a good spot I
think that was the guy shoved a rock and
uh yeah there's no heroes in this mode
apparently yeah which is great
more of your traditional clones versus
like rebel no resistance its first order
versus
hey laughs you think I got a grenade off
they got such good high ground now
yeah so you have 40 more tickets right
essentially or 40 more lives is that
what it is eggs you got to get it myself
flank on them fine it's about securing
the kill
oh what a bad time I mean dude that
isn't such a [ __ ] spot yeah what's
backwards normal yet now it's better
we'll have another run at it might be
the last run though oh yeah oh you got
34 come this way okay they got the
package there's someone I hope he comes
this way I feel like he's going through
that middle like cluster F of the spot
yeah that guy's like it's F that dumb
spot you're gonna wrap it around to the
back yeah yeah like it smart tactical
where at least there's like a ton of
cover in the woods and [ __ ] yeah and
your teammates will be there to kind of
hey guys follow the artifact good job
like we can manage if we're if we're
hugging on the like outside here Wow
look at that guy he's in the fray got
your back all right here we go trying to
get that artifact
oh there's so many dudes damn it it's
all good oh you could rock it soldier
did well here we go as many people as
mentioned have mentioned this game is
definitely more substantive for them
battlefield a channel frontpoint god
damn PF feel like they did that on
purpose
[Music]
no they brought it back Rob at least he
destroyed that wookie oh that's so good
Jesus you really can't get out it's
really hard to do this in the tree so
alright seventeen lives to get this
artifact come on stay on target
that was an accident
that guy's hurts my dad first day on the
job
sorry that
oh they're in this this is awkward I
[Laughter]
look like a really bad dance yeah we're
so done it's all good Val gaming I get
it Oh Russian fart oh I thought I was a
jet pack guy Thank You Juna you wish
yep killed the bra on Cilla bra dang it
that's shocking
hurry up you only have two tickets
you're the last two I think maybe does
that guy have the artifact sure you
gotta get up kick it up
oh no that's over there
oh gee Rob it's okay ot let's do what
you your your favorite mode let's let's
go to this yeah how about those day one
noobs huh hey goob that all the day one
noobs are obviously playing galactic
assault okay the biggest mode so far is
still level 10 only and let's say your
challenges are kind of locked once you
kind of do them self yeah trying to run
the game when I'm stuck on a loading
screen anyone with the same issue we
didn't have that of building
nope yeah you want to get out of here
we're gonna end with one or two matches
of starfighter assaults but yeah then
guys everyone for tuning in
yeah gamespot live we're playing
battlefront 2 open beta available for
everyone on Xbox one ps4 and PC PC of
course you're gonna need origin to
download it it's not on Steam but if you
want to play it you have until Monday 9
a.m. Pacific Standard Time and as Rob
alluded to it Monday Night Football is
win they will drop drop the last Jedi
trailer is the rumor right mm-hmm I
think it's gonna happen ok I was
checking these
no I want that who's playing that night
it's not a great game I think it's like
Minnesota Buffalo I want to say
[Music]
Minnesota and the bears which is even
worse than Minnesota Buffalo so yeah but
mitch true--but ski will be making his
rookie debut for those who actually know
who that guy is if not don't worry about
it yeah fund or fund or start off with
the old classic x-wing origin no deal
says mrs. old Walt it's free it's up to
you if you want it down later
yeah right on right on them
[Music]
but for those of you that don't know
this is a like starships only mode Rob
is running for his life from white Tie
Fighters and inner self oh nice do it
Rob you can shake this guy
maybe go inside oh yeah here we go
they'll never see this coming Oh guys I
think he died oh dude that would be so
sick if you kill them in there except I
feel like he's someone's still on you
Oh artoo we need you
are we going back in yeah oh yeah that's
right you wouldn't come in here yeah
dude that was nice oh how do you look
behind her up up on the d-pad oh damn
alright that's it
that is it now we're yep that's an AI
Rob
I'm not too sure skittles that we didn't
have that problem fortunately I hope
someone your chat
Redman Casey will go to a wing gonna get
to some speed had some had some good
runs did you yeah ice cream because Eric
I have some star cards that are that are
on it and they're really good all right
engage that's ours
never sight coming
generators do it
all right good some objective face
gaming here
let's scratch the paint a little bit if
it was he's doing a good job of like
lighting up his job before actually
thank you
oh you know it might be turrets outside
when I'm passing these openings
it's a good Warcraft
oh I feel like that was your fault
yeah totally like you had a judge to
rock out of the way I just saw
he's like I'm trying to make a bombing
really did that dude go the other way I
was like dude this is my kill I totally
sit sorry
you gotta sis
this is cool though yeah I like this
[ __ ]
remember remember laughs what no hug
mode writing pre-order I'm guessing it's
depends on to which version you select
but yeah open beta is free so playback
okay all right good confident Ruth it's
like killing grunts in PFD yeah all
right fine rack it up Rob
maybe you'll get out of here oh here oh
[ __ ] this guy yeah this guy not so much
this guy
[Music]
laia trying to lock on to him
nice work well y-wing oh well he can't
catch up hey Rob not always probably on
speed is too fast
yeah 1,500
oh is that gonna go
oh so close
right
obvious doing work without a wig later
viva la absurd
ah gotcha Gabi that guy what do I need I
really want this x-wing okay keep going
then you're at 2,100 I think you're
gonna get there are there any health
pickups no but you had like a repairing
thing I think right yeah that's like the
last game there aren't health pickups
but I think what's more with a better
system is that you can recharge your
health there it just killed me get
revenge once you like get away so like
you can you can always stay alive
opposed to like the last game yeah you
needed like find health pickups
excellent tie why you run into us
how's my father oh I can't watch I want
to place as our sky car
don't worry here we go cockpit view
oh oh oh close another one hopefully the
Imperials yeah
[Applause]
BAM I feel like you're real close real
close to the Millennium Falcon that's
for sure
well I also joined lowly I think why did
that guy user I didn't see any of the
hero ships harden your side someone had
just bought in in the po PO's exhale
really yeah I must win him but no it's
too late that's the problem
brother download is so slow sorry but I
hope check this out waiting here we go
all right you gotta get that slave boy I
want that slave one so bad
there we go let us start already 30
seconds look at these cards I have here
sometimes that's what you got to run to
the bathroom and go back so I got
increases my fire rate and my resistance
to over can you board other vessels no
valor gave me also saying I feel you our
sky he wants to play too glad you guys
are tuning in until you guys can play
but Rob's on the sticks slash mouse
keyboard doing a very good job in the
space battles
yes the rebels away
[Music]
all right
can you reach level 5 for classes and
data to allow two cards yes you can
reach level 10 10 this seems to be the
maximum don't know if anything more
warlock after that but
my overall yeah because you have a
couple characters that have three star
card dirty I'd make I think my officer
is and my specialist okay yes the more
you play the more you'll be able to the
thing to remember those that none of
this stuff here is over
I saw what you're going for there so
there's a double kill particle
it's that boost the booze is so loud
515 battle points we're like like a six
away from the cleanest boat
each class does have its own level right
Rob like yeah class rank yeah it does
it's like it's like bow filled one holy
God you get out of this pretty amazing
oh wow
we have one cruiser remain
maybe a boy down these guys you're just
trying to get a slave one right Jerry
you're not going anywhere dice shooter
we gonna bust out the Millennium Cockrum
definitely can't hear but we're trying
to bust out the slave 1
what's up horsey
currently playing Starfighter assaults
in Battlefront 2 beta thank you guys for
tuning in open beta active so you guys
can also download I want it oh my hat
you're at like a thousand four hundred
so we keep up the pace you're at you
should be able to get the slave yeah I'm
sorry I'm begging people dizzy happens
when you're not have to fly in the yeah
when you're controlling it I'm sure
[Music]
so cool-looking that's come on you're
gonna be fine
ironic I want it so Eric la the or Galit
he customization comes with the star
cards there he has one that shoots
faster and nothing at the other one that
he had mentioned
you guys are beasts that's mainly Rob I
like to think I'm a beast as we can say
yeah you are that guy in particular
smells teamplay that's fine
we can stop these rebels from shooting
your shield
[Music]
I don't even think I was able to use my
speed boost because I was disabled
you're okay
you guys gonna get down like a shield
generator is telling you to protect
thing I don't even know if they're still
up anymore
who might be on the conduit over I mean
I don't see any guys in here
who had like a little chicken fight
there oh I got him
I don't know it didn't seem like he
actually died
oh yeah no no I turn nope no what your
ass getting closer
you haven't really told I can kill this
thing
yeah
oh why was it Shh what are we at no 1887
we're closed we just need 700 just need
a couple more kills
[Music]
there's no point killing those guys
already on earth on the way out that guy
ah photon torpedoes 1900 come on Rob you
can do it I believe no it's not
happening
why six percent five percent is there
anything after the shields projectors
yeah
game over s what's after not on your
watch
yeah see what I say I'll do oh oh
millenium Falcone well that's a given
still good
Viterbo is another
well they got after the clamps the
couplings right so we have one more
objective where we can hold them off and
hopefully get the slave
[Music]
yeah it's gonna be starting to take it
out
slow down my friends Wow
nice you got the assist on
okay you know I was thinking already got
one yeah
if the y-wing is the Odyssey of the
world what the hell is going on Falcon
frickin big ol suburban yeah Escalade I
think you got a really good
he doesn't have Luke Skywalker back
there sheet in your year you the hero
that we deserve what's stuck for them
yeah he's probably really annoyed huh Oh
friends do you have it no yeah yeah oh
wait you think so I think I'll buy that
same thing it's it's it's a good way to
go out of the stream we should wait
we're waiting we're gonna wait he'll
hang the weight he'll die you think so
sure does the Millennium the Millennium
Falcon cost less or more than the hose
yeah I would be this it would probably
be the same okay passenger van
yeah oh there it is good call here we go
boosters music oh my god it sounds so
good
[Laughter]
in the world like how he wasted it
that's okay he'll come back
you're getting record I shouldn't have
wasted it
in everyone bye
[Music]
leave us alone whatever I don't care
I honestly don't care I didn't care I
really just wanted to do that noise I
swear to God ah so cool god I wanted to
eat a wreck shop I know I know I feel
bad and people probably annoyed but I
genuinely just wanted to do that what
the hell was that
okay we've to get explain what it was
that's a seismic charge it's just it's
from the original repo the prequels it's
not the slave one it's Jango Fett's move
that he had but man I died pretty quick
though surprising actually well you were
going to town on the morning and falcons
yeah
but i definitely had more than one guy
on my store
god that is the coolest [ __ ] thing
kind of bewildered by that last sound
effects worth it says Matt Moore so dude
so worth it
Wow overhyped
what's up apex Marilyn Hawkins what do
you all think about battlefront type
game with only heroes and villains with
the story mode playing through the
events of episode 137
all that Rob answer that later I'm sorry
well with no you're good I'll ask you
later with you're not in the midst of a
dog fight yeah we're trying to take down
a ship that looks like the Leia ship now
it is blockade runner all right go
figure
so
what do y'all think about a Bal fright
Battlefront type game with only heroes
and villains the story playing episode 7
so you're you're talking about this game
but only heroes and villains alright do
you do only here there is a mode like
that well there's a mode that's heroes
and villains just like the last one it's
not here it's not here in beta he's
somewhat a story mode like that maybe
yeah see what the story mode yeah I
guess I don't
yeah I mean that'd be nice he's talking
like a single-player game yeah a
single-player game would be cool what's
up Pikachu him you want to show some
customization actually and then oh we
can probably wrap this up here sure back
to my gamer hip real quick
have you got enough points open to
create your favorite maybe not from that
last round just a cool seismic charge oh
yeah that's 100 cool let's see your
mouse works here we go what are you
gonna purchase so I actually have been
granted this is beta but I opened a
Starfire crate and it guarantees one
Starfire card I opened one they did not
get one okay
so let's hope that gets fixed this is
more hero stuff right yeah one it's
guaranteed a hero card so no thanks it's
to a trooper what's up homie Pikachu
super crate you guys want to open up
it's not confirmed on General Grievous
but I'm right there with you have you so
cool well we get I'm shot for no it's
for something else a common weapon
modifier oh wait it is it is a tube
that's poop so it's so here this is the
thing is here if this is the first card
I've had that is actually a duplicate
cuz I already I already got this so I
should I don't think I can but I should
be able to turn that into crafting parts
okay but I don't think I can in this
beta at least definitely I do that was
for the specialist I can go back and
double-check okay
defuser the homie Pikachu is on ps4 Xbox
one and PC on PC you're gonna need to
use origin to download it though show
some of that so I have also 130 crashing
fires I can do it I can make a little
crafting part move but let's see here
data is free
George Berta's open beta this weekend
until Monday 9:00 a.m. Pacific time
which is about three and a half hours
from earlier than from now alright well
I totally had a duplicate anything
didn't do anything at least right now in
the beta I was trying on the beta so
that's a bombers I didn't I'm not
I like that joy this yeah I don't know
what to say that's kind of a bummer hard
action that's kind of a bummer start so
those these are star cards this is it
this is it but like this can be a star
card can you craft cards yet I can't so
let's craft one for say the specialists
have been kind of focusing on that so we
can upgrade it to you you can upgrade it
only to alleged epic I think and then
there are apparently legendary cards I'm
think I've gone one yet and legendaries
are the best cards you can only get them
through loot crate's and they also have
like a status effect so let's no no no I
don't do it why I don't want to spend
forty parts on that this is apparently
really good okay then do it then
I've been seen I've been seeing people
like one shot me with this [ __ ] okay
then do it have like a level ten version
though so that's what that's what it is
like a terrifying fear is that like I
what if I bought that or put crafting
parts into it which are very hard to get
my opinion and then like I rolled a
lucre and got it you know what I mean or
like a higher or higher version of it
it's like great feel bad it would be
frustrating I could try this or I could
upgrade I don't know you can't okay that
one that was epic right so maybe I'm
wrong
maybe this oh no you just don't have
enough parts that's what it is
oh you're right 480 that's gonna take
two years there's got to be a faster way
and when the game comes out you have to
imagine there anything else the people
wants to see there's my house
will there be microtransaction for parts
or cosmetic items there will be what's
been announced is that there will be
you'll be able to buy crates with real
world money but it's not clear on what
type of crates like I would be
personally frustrated very frustrated if
that they had legendary crates oh that
guarantees that guarantee you one
legendary item because that's that's
[ __ ] because it's like the
difference between like I think in the
the difference like let's say the
Stinger pistol they're right if you made
one or you had the lowest here was like
six plus six damage where's like
legendaries like plus ten yeah or plus
and who knows how much like how much
that influences like the game because
then it's like we're talking about
yesterday it's like well you're one be
wanting does that guy have like a
legendary version of the gun like this
is that it tells you yeah I know so like
once you lose that fight you're like oh
[ __ ] no wonder a lot like I feel like I
lost pose maybe that or was it skill
right and you see his cards oh he's got
three legendary cards I have to because
I just started I have two cards that are
like uncommon because I just started the
game it's frustrating and you know what
I will say is that like when we did this
room yesterday house fly around the
ailing and even just now like I have to
pretty damn good cards on that thing
just to and I noticed the difference
okay like higher fire rate and
a shorter cooldown like I was surprised
damn I'd remember this being good and
then yeah when we finished the stream
yesterday when looked I was like oh we
have yeah well I have to pretty good
star cards on it okay
so that's a little scary for me yeah
we'll have to see when the actual game
comes out and yeah it's hard to tell
it's still beta things gonna get tweaked
and modified so but yeah that's kind of
a look at the the crafting system and
like the star cards and we pray you guys
saw as well which you earn credits for
but when the real game comes out
November 17th I believe you'll be able
to potentially buy some crates and we
don't know what those crates look like
yet but you know be sure to stay tuned
to games what calm because we will of
course cover that once it comes out I'm
trying to think of what we what's coming
on this weekend I know we just did the
shadow of war review that's up you got
any other big planned stuff coming up
this weekend
I'm I'm seeing a Blade Runner tonight
nice so the interesting thing is I've
heard nothing but good things prior
until talking to one friend last night
who thought it was just okay
oh really yeah but everyone else I've
ever known is like yeah Blade Runner is
good I might watch it this weekend - I
don't recall that much of the first one
like I think I watched it but I kind of
don't either like I was maybe too young
to remember there's no Harrison Ford so
anyways yeah so all the talking talking
talking is because we're wrapping up the
stream but thank you guys all for tuning
in
we're live every day at 11 a.m. and yeah
thanks Rob for playing thank you for
your day today we're hanging out in
chatting with chat well I got to play
this pretty fun game liking it
Starfighter mode especially it's great
open beta til Monday 9 a.m. Pacific
enjoy it go download it have fun have
fun this weekend and until next time see
you guys Monday maybe
[Music]